welcome everybody thanks for coming to
this session so I'm Evan Tripp lucky I'm
the designer of the Elm programming
language and I got started on it about
seven years ago with a paper called Elm
concurrent FRP for functional goos and I
was like I really think I can make this
functional programming stuff easier and
I didn't nail it immediately with that
title but I had this idea of this
experience with typed functional
programming that was really joyful and
what I wanted to get out with Elm was
like I wanted to take that part that I
felt was so fun and make it accessible
to other people and share that joy that
I had felt and so part of that is
technical you know you have to write a
compiler and all this kind of stuff but
another part is like practical stuff
like getting set up it should be easy
and that was part of what was important
to me having spent a whole day just
trying to learn something trying to see
if something was interesting and being
really frustrated another piece of that
was if program is gonna be fun I want
that community be friendly I didn't want
it to be a cool Club for the cool kids
you know oh we're functional programmers
and you're not because you're dumb like
I didn't I didn't relate to that I just
had a nice time programming and I wanted
to share that nice time in the same way
that I like sushi and I might say hey
you should try it out it's pretty nice
and so I might say no thanks oh okay you
know like it's a that's the kind of
interactions like I wanted to have
because it was just about having this
experience so as I've talked to more
open-source developers people who design
languages people work on databases
people work on machine learning or
discussion platforms or environmental
sensors however much we disagree on
design or what where our goals are we
all have stories in common about like
having a friendly community is really
really difficult and that's one of the
places an open-source where you know as
good as you can be the technical stuff
like you don't have a lot of you
ultimately you can't control what's
gonna
happen and if someone's gonna yell it's
like I wish that didn't happen so I've
been doing this for about seven years
now and I've started to notice some
patterns of behavior that I think
probably a lot of people who worked in
open-source with larger priors will
relate to so one is this why don't you
just and in elements like why don't you
just get the jsapi directly or release
an incremental version instead of a
bigger release or hey can we derived yes
json decoders and the short answer in
all these cases is that it's more
complex than it sounds like if if
there's something that you can think of
in five minutes or an hour or a day
probably someone has thought about that
and considered it and there might be
implications that you don't see from
your perspective but someone else in the
community might have a problem with that
it's not obvious to you so when you're
doing design you know why don't you just
it's like well there's all these
different parties that we have to sort
of make things work for and I can do my
best on my intuition but ultimately even
after I spend like a week trying to
design something that way I need to go
out and show it to people and see what
objections they bring and then do maybe
do with another dessert so this why
don't you just is like it's a it's it's
it's quite frustrating and one thing
that happens is there's a lot of people
who are new to the project so maybe
there's 10,000 people who might be
curious like oh why don't you just try
out this kind of thing and the number of
people who know the full context is
pretty small so maybe there's like 10 20
people so if it takes five minutes to
say why don't you just blah blah blah
and it takes two pages of writing and
you have to write it very carefully
because if you're influential community
member people will refer back to what
you said four or five years ago and say
like man there's such a jerk here here's
the evidence they said this in 2013 and
it's like yeah yeah yeah I said that in
2013 yes
so one thing that's that's common is
like well if it's so much work like why
don't you just delegate the work right
so this is a comment I got in real life
and italics are from the person talking
to me they said there's another way to
deal with this like delegation and then
they go on to describe how delegation
works and what benefits it might have I
was like ha very interesting yes I
hadn't thought about that and they
described a person who can do all this
work and they say there's somebody again
that is there italics can also be a
proxy who's gathering feedback so like
you don't have to be in these
discussions but so I was initially very
upset about this
so like the unfiltered in my own mind
version was like oh hello is this the
somebody store yes we'd like someone to
take unsolicited advice on the Internet
oh yeah it's it's a really mean yeah
it's gonna be rough and no yeah no one's
gonna say thank you
yeah no it's it's unpaid yeah it's
unpaid it takes the air takes on you you
don't have any well I was told there
would be somebody who would do this and
you know so this was me in my own life
like walking around my room just like
and that's you know that's not a healthy
place to be that's not how I want to
look to a community that's not what I
want the community I'm a part of - to be
either and when I took some time and
thought about it more I realized there's
actually like a pretty reasonable
assumption going on here which is like
free rice means you can take as much as
you want the rice is free take a lot of
rice and so does that imply that free
labor means you can use as much as you
want
well the labor is free but in fact this
isn't how labor works if you don't pay
for labor you get less and so I think
that's sort of the root thing it's like
oh well it should be unlimited anyone
can help now let's assume it is
unlimited that everybody in the world
actually
and help in practice you actually have
to work together right these are highly
technical projects are you able to work
well together is your goals with the
project aligned how much time does it
take to coordinate with that person to
get stuff done so even if you can work
with anybody you want there's still
these limitations on like who is gonna
be really effective in doing the right
stuff so I wrote about that a little bit
in this post I think or no sorry Richard
wrote about that in this post here of
like what actually does it take to get
involved and it's like it's it's a it's
not just somebody store so you know some
people may be thinking like you know
Evan you're doing a lot of telling us
what's the situation but like who are
you to say that and so this is another
pattern that I see a lot is like on
whose authority and this is actually the
title of a post that was sent to the
closure community and the post started
out eff closure there I said it
and God feels good
I say it with much admiration and
respect to all the community members and
then they go on to say some criticisms
and talk about the relationship with
women and it's it's quite a
rollercoaster of a post but what's
interesting besides sort of like it like
it as a journal entry is that it gets a
lot of engagement right so three hundred
and twenty comments on the reddit thread
I'm sure people talked about it in other
contexts as well where there would have
been more comments and you know as
someone who's been working on an
open-source project for a bunch of years
now enough people have told me that Elm
is gonna die next month that I'm like I
don't think you're there right this time
you know like I have that that in two or
like I have that that fear doesn't speak
to me anymore because I have the
experience but there are other people in
the community who don't have that same
experience and like this can be like a
scary thing of like man people like
aren't liking this thing are we doing
something wrong they feel like maybe
they it could be better they might get
defensive so in one of these 320
comments the creator of closure says I
found out about this while sitting down
to spend my weekend contributing to the
closure ecosystem time spent in Lua
spending time with my wife having
already spent my workweek on other
closure related stuff and I relate to
this a lot I've definitely written like
hey like we I get there's different
viewpoints but like we can't yell our
viewpoints at each other and that was my
Saturday and you know as you work over
the course of the years like there can
only be so many Saturdays that are like
that before it starts to hurt you in
larger ways so rich Hickey
goes on to say you know every time I
have to process a diatribe like this
aftermath the effects on myself my
family and my co-workers I have to
struggle back from why should I bother
and every time it gets harder justified
on myself and my family that it's worth
the time and I
emotional burden now I've talked to some
people about this post and they thought
different things stood out to me this
last part is what stands out because I
think a lot of people and opensource
feel this way and like would never say
it out loud I was really surprised to
see it that way and it kind of gave me
some confidence to talk about that kind
of stuff as well so you know we have our
post like this in the Elam community
with a bunch of comments as well and I
see it not just as like oh man this is
hard for me to process but the people I
work with have a hard time processing it
and then if you just add up all the time
let's say maybe 10 minutes is spent on
each of these comments what I think is
low like a conservative estimate we're
talking about like 50 hours for this one
that that's just like dealing with
someone's anger and could that have been
helping someone new or spending time
with some family members or like
learning some hobby that could get you
out of work and get you like a more
healthy attitude so one thing I hear a
lot when I talk about this stuff is like
if it makes you so mad why don't you
just not read it why don't you just not
read it
so another pattern that's really common
is that all discussion is constructive
you know I'm just saying how I feel I
feel like s you and I respect you a lot
and you know I think you're an idiot but
like I really learned a lot from you and
like that's a difficult like personal
relations to have I don't know if people
have people like that in their life but
that's a difficult thing to deal with a
lot so one discussion that was along
these lines is like should Elm have user
definable infix operators this came up
recently with our recent release and if
we just focus on this question like
textually someone might say yeah there
are cases where it makes code shorter
and more convenient and someone else
might say no because it can make code
harder to read especially from in a
large team and you know text really like
this is an interesting area mate like
yeah it can make cloture that's a good
point and it might hurt people on a
large team and then onlookers will sort
of say which one seems to make more
sense to me but when you take a step
back and stop think if it just is like a
textual argument and who's wrong and say
okay all these people have different
priorities some of them may value
flexibility a lot and some people might
value simplicity a lot and all these
people exist on this with different
priorities so that person is like yeah
we should have this really might value
flexibility and the person who says no
is saying well if like all these
benefits you're telling me about
flexibility or like how code can be
shorter and more convenient it's like
that's not persuasive to me like that's
not a good rational argument because
it's just not important
and it's likewise you know how does it
work on a large team it's like well that
doesn't it doesn't matter it's not about
that
and all the people exist on this
spectrum is or with different priorities
as well so they're evaluating it not as
which is the true objective argument but
given my priorities which is the one
that makes the most sense to me so I've
come to see
directive discussion is about mutual
understanding rather than mutual
agreement and a lot of discussions
online are like we're going to get to a
point where you agree with me rather
than saying like huh
this person's seeing it different why is
that maybe they're seeing something I
don't so when I take a step back and
think about these different patterns I
just think like why why is this
happening you know I I don't have
problems like this in normal life you
know if I'm at an elm conference or a
meet-up
or like nothing ever is so emotionally
difficult as these interactions so I
found this documentary called all
watched over by machines of loving grace
by Adam Curtis it's excellent as is all
of his work and that sort of taught me
or I found through that a book called
from counterculture to cyber culture so
this revealed to me a sort of an
intellectual history going back to the
1950s that really helps explain what's
going on in open-source right now so it
traces things from a book called the
human use of human beings so this came
out of MIT in like 1952 by a person who
had created artillery that could
automatically track planes and shoot
them down and then the whole earth
catalogue which was popular in back to
the land movement so a lot of people in
communes might have bought this but it
was a much larger thing than that and
then finally the Electronic Frontier
Foundation and it sort of ties these
together in a very interesting way so
we'll look at some of the the things
going on here so in the human use of
human beings Norbert Wiener introduces
the idea of cybernetics he defines it as
the study of messages has a means of
controlling machinery and society it's a
little weird
okay okay fine and as you start to read
it it's like the this this way of like
let's not look at the person but let's
look at the messages going around and
that's how we'll think about how the
world works and so you see things like
words such as life purpose and soul are
grossly inadequate to pursue precise
scientific thinking which is it's like
fair enough but also like those things
like life and purpose are like pretty
important to people as well to consider
but you know a person is just a special
sort of machine for hey like we can
consider it as a thing that takes inputs
and does stuff emotions are just a
useless epiphenomena that's a that's
that's real he said that another thing
is like we have modified our environment
so radically that we must have modify
ourselves in order to exist in this new
environment so it's sort of how can we
take a person and simplify it down to a
machine or a system that we can
understand well and then once we're
starting to think of people that way
well we can improve machines we can add
things to them and the machines get more
capabilities maybe that's how we move
forward as as people and life and
purposes like that we can't go back to
that then it's too different now
so the sort of connecting thread and
Whole Earth Catalog besides Stewart
Brand author of this knowing a bunch of
the people in a cybernetics group is
this idea of access to tools right so
like we're not we we are now our
relationship with our tools is going to
be how we move forward so this catalog
starts with we are as gods and we might
as well get good at it so far remotely
done power and glory as government big
business formal education church has
succeeded to the point where the gross
defects obscure actual gains in response
personal power is developing so he's
focused on a bunch of different topics
and so education finding inspiration
shape
his environment sharing the adventure
now keep in mind this is written in 1969
so this is before the internet and if
you read these points as like what ideal
view of the Internet should be it works
really well like you can find out all
sorts of interesting stuff you can be
inspired by what's going on up there you
can find a place where you really fit in
even if you don't fit in in your local
community that has different values than
you and you can share that with whoever
you want to like there's this place for
self expression and so he says tools
that aid this process are sought and
promoted by the Whole Earth Catalog so
some people have argued that this is
sort of like the what preceded the
internet had sort of foresaw what was
going to happen there and this
publication and the Creator Stewart
Brand had been really influential so one
of the positive quotes is when I was
young there was amazing publication
called the Whole Earth Catalog which was
one of the Bible's of my generation so
that was Steve Jobs there was a project
that's doer brand created called the
10,000 year clock which deaf Bezos
helped fund with 42 million dollars so
what is this like this book that was
popular on back-to-the-land communes
became very influential because of this
how tools and like a rejection of
hierarchy where somehow in this new
place where we're going to choose our
own future through our connection with
tools and finally the Electronic
Frontier Foundation interestingly the
founders of this met on the whole earth
electronic link one of the earliest
bullet or message boards and so one of
the founders wrote the Declaration of
Independence of cyberspace governments
of the industrial world you weary Giants
of flesh and steel you have no
sovereignty where we gather I declare
the global space social space we are
building to be naturally independent of
the tyranny as you seek to impose on us
so again you see this like distrust of
hierarchy big businesses failed
government has failed we are going to
find a new way through this thing so one
of the early cases
Electronic Frontier Foundation but that
inspired the creation of this foundation
was there was a programmer called Lloyd
Blankenship and BellSouth found that
some of their 911 Alexus tum'
documentation had been posted on a
bulletin board and so they got the
Secret Service involved and took some
computers that might have sensitive
information so Lloyd was arrested and
the Electronic Frontier Foundation like
was created around that time to help
protect people in this situation so
after Lloyd was arrested he wrote
something called the hackers manifesto
which I think gives a raw version of
what's going on in this world so he says
I'm smarter than most of the other kids
this crap they teach us bores me I've
listened to my teacher explain for the
15th time how to reduce a fraction I
understand it no Miss Smith I didn't
show my work I did it in my head and you
can see well he says I've made a
discovery today I found a computer it
does what I want it to do if I make a
mistake it's because I screwed up not
because it doesn't like me or it feels
threatened by me or it thinks I'm a
smart ass where it doesn't like teaching
and shouldn't be here so you're seeing
this this guy's 21 when he's writing
this he's somebody sort of very
disillusioned not just with government
or big business but like just his
classroom the social environment he's
living in and he goes on to say this is
our world now we explore but you call us
criminals you build atomic bombs wage
wars he's tried to make us believe it's
for our own good yet we're the criminals
so again you see that explicit distrust
of hierarchy and then finally my crime
is that about smarting you something you
will never forgive me for so III don't
know how many people who work on open
source will recognize aspects of this
attitude and interactions they have but
there's sort of such a strong rejection
of the social things going on it's like
well the teacher who's not teaching you
well has a bunch of other students
and it's difficult to balance all their
needs like it may be it's malicious but
maybe there's another reason but this
world use kind of like I don't smart it
like you don't see it how I see it
so when I take a step back on this
intellectual pathway like things I sort
of draw out from reading these books and
endings is one where we're gods to
hierarchy has failed us there's sort of
a deep distrust of hierarchical
structures I think you know rightly
there's a lot of bad things that come
out of hierarchy and finally order will
emerge from the new technology so when
we reconsider the patterns we've seen
open source stuff makes a lot of sense
so it's like why don't you just it's
like haven't you like we can just
through reason and rationality like
figure out the answer like why don't you
just do the obvious thing hierarchy has
failed us so again on whose authorities
coming out of this tradition of
hierarchical structures haven't served
as well we need to find a way that isn't
structured in that way like your
authority as the author is not
legitimate on those grounds and all
discussion is constructive it's like
well this is the new technology this is
what the new technology is producing so
this must be the way forward to this
place that we want to go so I found this
pathway really interesting and and it
informed like it helped me understand a
lot was going on but it's just one of a
couple of different ways of looking at
how we got to this level of conflict in
open-source so I'm calling this sort of
the the intellectual history of like
freedom people people were primarily
prioritizing freedom but there are other
ones such as people who are primarily
prioritizing engagement so I want to
start with a quote the enormous
expansion of communications has entirely
transformed the conditions of trade and
commerce everything is done in haste at
fever pitch the night is used for travel
today for business even holiday trips
put strain on the nervous system and to
people relate to that holiday trips
being stressful I feel
where I struggle with that at least I
tried I try to you know take a break or
whatever great political industrial and
financial crises carry this a segment
into far wider areas of population than
ever before interest in political life
has become universal tempers are
inflamed by political religious and
social struggles party politics
electioneering finally people are forced
to engage in a constant mental activity
and robbed of the time you defer
relaxation sleep and rest so if you had
to guess when this was written let's see
it's reasonable it could be this year it
could be 2017 or maybe someone was
really prophetic and they wrote it in
like 1980 it's like I see where this is
all going so this is actually from
something Freud wrote in 1902 the part I
left out is due to the worldwide
Telegraph and telephone networks and the
immense growth of trade unionism so I
mean I think it makes sense that he
would have seen these kinds of things he
seems like a smart dude or at least
someone who's very sensitive to human
behavior and so this is kind of where
this intellectual history starts so we
have Freud but we're gonna look at two
other books one is called propaganda
from 1928 and one is called nudge much
more recent from 2008 so with propaganda
this is written by Edward Bernays this
is actually Freud's nephew the
connections between all these works are
crazy and as you look into any parts of
these like everybody met everybody
worked with someone's nephew or cousin
or mom or it's very strange so this book
is essentially a bunch of stories about
how Edward Bernays should have created
the idea of public relations so one of
the stories he tells is about torches of
freedom so this was an ad campaign to
break the taboo against women smoking at
the time men would smoke and it was
acceptable to some degree and women
couldn't it was a very looked down upon
so the president of the American tobacco
company
said if we can break this taboo it'll be
like a gold mine opening right in front
right in our front yard so he hires
Edward Bernays and what Edward Bernays
does is he hires women who are
good-looking but not too modely that's
the the quote I found good-looking but
not too modely to walk in an Easter
Sunday parade and smoke he also hired
photographers to get really good photos
of these women and then distributed
those photos to newspaper like through
newspaper connections that he had to
make sure he got published all around
the world
so this torches of freedom idea was
saying we see this trend about women's
liberation happening and like this is
aligned with that movement in that this
is a way of punching up against those
taboos but it's very focused on like hey
we're gonna sell a bunch of we're gonna
make a bunch of money here and so one of
the ads that came out of this was an
ancient precious has been removed and
what's interesting about this ad is that
visually it's clearly about women
smoking but texturally it's saying
toasting did it it's because they toast
the tobacco it's less harsh on your
throat and that's what has removed the
prejudice
so texturally they can say look we're
not getting into politics we were just
saying that toasting is cool and that's
a lady who smokes it's like that's I
don't see the problem
but meanwhile you have hired Edward
Bernays to actually run this campaign so
oh yeah I want to read a little bit of -
from his book this is the book he says
the old-fashioned propagandist using
almost exclusively the appeal to the
printed word tried to persuade the
individual reader to buy a definite
article immediately so he's like his
example of this is like you buy
O'Leary's rubber bands now and he's like
okay that's the old-fashioned way
the modern propagandist therefore sets
to work to create the circumstances that
will modify the custom right it doesn't
matter what this ad says it's about
creating circumstances such that the
cost
we'll change in whatever direction
someone pays me to change it so another
example he gives is for Mozart pianos so
I don't know exactly the finances of
Mozart pianos but let's say they had 30
percent of market share and he gets had
to make it higher maybe can go to 35 or
40 I'd be a huge for Mozart pianos so
Bernays comes in he says okay I could
say to people will you please buy a
piano but I'm not going to do that I
know that pianos have this sort of elite
cachet and so what I'm going to do is I
want to make a architecture Expo in New
York City where we're going to showcase
music parlors and we're going to bring
in famous people influential artists and
musicians to be in the rooms we're going
to have expensive tapestries and really
lean into this elite picture and promote
it in our connections with newspapers he
also invites architects from all over
the country he wants influential
architects and they'll bring designs
from music parlors so what this Expo
does is it creates a music parlor as a
aspirational goal and it brings in
architects who will then go back to
wherever they're from with designs for
music parlors and they'll start building
houses that have that and ideally
they'll influence other architects who
are not as influential to add music
parlors as well and so instead of saying
hey will you please buy this piano
people are now saying have this piano
shaped hole that I need to fill like do
you have a something piano shaped so
again the modern propagandist sets to
work to create the circumstances that
will modify the custom so this got
modernized and sort of made a bit nicer
in nudge so here we see a nudge is any
aspect of a choice architecture that
will alter people's behavior in a
predictable way without forbidding any
options or seemingly changing their
economic incentives so this book has
been really a fun influential in tech
recently so one thing that we're
probably all familiar that's an example
of this is autoplay of videos so you
just finished a show it ends on a
cliffhanger because they wrote it that
way
and you're like man that was that was
cool and you're like oh my body
is it is it hungry does it need a walk
did it have plans for today or for
anything and then the music starts again
and you're like no no so this is this is
a nudge right you're free to do some
other behavior but you know through the
choice architecture that was created a
predictable amount of people don't don't
make that free choice so this ended up
being popular at Google so if anyone's
visited Google Google cafeterias you'll
probably have seen and all the food is
marked with colors so green means eat
anytime yellow means once in a while red
means not often please and it's all
marked it's actually very helpful you
can be like oh I just had one red thing
today it's kind of nice but this
interest in like colors changing
people's behavior was used at Google and
in other ways so when you look at the
history of their ad labeling you see
something similar so when ad started
they sort of just start by playing
around with colors it's like whoa maybe
Green is like fun or like maybe this
like lavender purple thing is like the
way to go so in a new phase of things
you start to see okay well how let's
let's do something more like more can it
be something more white okay yeah maybe
a little more white you know well how
about something like a little more white
like at all this colors like let's just
put it in one place we'll take all the
saturation put it in one place and like
hey it works fine no problem and then
it's like well that you yellows pretty
ugly like we could just you know it's
still labeled it's no problem and then
it's like I mean who who wanted it to be
yellow and I mean it wasn't it wasn't
really that important and then it's like
you know the background
I mean people get it they get it so when
you search for Italy tour for example
everything above the fold is an ad and
it's labeled in this very you know
subtle and and nice way so I found this
very interesting quote from the head of
text ads at Google he says we want to
make it easier for our users to adjust
information on the page so we're
gradually trying to reduce the number of
variations of colors and patterns on the
page and bring a little bit more harmony
to the page like we just we just want
harmony and that's why we reduced one of
the color elements on the page we could
have reduced other color elements it's
just one color element like what's the
big deal so some of you may be thinking
like Evan if you're so mad about this
you know why don't you just change your
default search like you have you typed
it into Safari so clearly that's default
well another thing I learned when I was
looking into this is Google paid 1
billion to Apple to keep the search
apart iPhones furthermore these sums
called traffic acquisition costs rose to
5.5 billion dollars or 23% of the ad
revenue so we're in a situation where a
choice architecture has been created you
know the the circumstances have been
modified such that you know well I don't
mind searching in this way or I could
scroll down below these ads but I don't
really want to
so the circumstances have been created
such that custom is modified and if we
wanted to mess with this like it's gonna
cost a lot of money right the fact that
I that DuckDuckGo exists doesn't mean
that they can compete with these kinds
of numbers so I think this whole
intellectual lineage leads to something
that we see in online communities a lot
which is like this things are viral by
design so when Bernays starts an
advertising campaign all these stories
he tells he always starts with a
psychological hook so you might observe
that people process emotions
sharing them with others so that might
look like you know someone's going about
their day it's fine
and someone shows up and they're like
that work you did last week it was
terrible like it's not gonna work out it
was really not carefully considered and
that person feels sad and that person
goes the the person ailing of them goes
away so they might mope around for a day
or however long and hopefully they run
into a friend who hears the story
they're like oh man that sucks but you
know I don't think that was really a
fair assessment like and through talking
it through the person can sort of deal
with that and move through another
interaction that might be possible as
you're going about your day and someone
says did you hear about that terrible
thing that's happening over there and
you say wow that's terrible and then you
see a friend you say hey did you hear
about that oh my god that's terrible and
they see some of their friends you're
like man that thing over there is really
bad I roll right so when we're choosing
what kind of messages we want to put
into society to control it as the
cyberneticist might say this one has a
very interesting pattern right so when
you get something has a viral reaction
that's something that has more
engagement and a lot of people who are
running Silicon Valley companies an
idealistic way you know they want to
make the world better through tools
they're put in this trace architecture
where it's like you have you know these
investors and you don't want to
disappoint them there's all these people
who work at your company you don't want
to lay them off so do you want hashtag
disappointing q3 or do you want the
viral one so once you have this
psychological hook you can start
designing ways to make it work better so
the ones I sort of noticed have been to
mix extremes so if we come back to our
priorities graph of different people
these people don't necessarily
congregate in the same place but what we
really want to happen is for the most
extreme people to yell at each other as
aggressively as possible and so one way
to do that might be to put all the
different programming communities in one
place
[Laughter]
so if you look at sort of different
online discussion forums I think the
degree to which different communities
collide will predict the amount of
conflict that you see there so in hacker
news I find that the sort of most
difficult most combative place and then
on the our program and you'll see more
that and on the subreddits for
individual languages you'll see less on
places that are just community places
that don't have accounts that are shared
between you'll see less so another
approach is to decontextualize the
person so instead of two people talking
you're you have tango tango talking to
Foxtrot and what's interesting here is
like when they saw each other's faces
they might be able to say oh this person
isn't trying to be malicious they feel
this way but when it's tango tango it
could literally be Hitler it could you
don't know is this in Argentina being
like in fix operators are stupid unclean
so another way to decontextualize things
is to limit the amount of characters
that are available to people another way
is to limit the kind of feedback that's
available so instead of saying hey that
was pretty hurtful you say down I got a
lot of nuances lost in that sort of
thing so when I take a step back on all
this I think there's a big conflict here
where there's very powerful incentives
for our interactions to go really poorly
and I don't think the intellectual
history of freedom really is well set up
to protect against that like if you are
living in a choice architecture that
predictably alters people's behavior
yeah you were given a free choice but
you happen to choose a different thing
30% of the time so this got me
interested in a different pathway so I
asked a lot why don't I have any of
these problems in person so like at work
or at conferences or it meet ups or on
the street all these places are for or
something
right so when a place is for something
you can ask what's inappropriate
behavior if I'm at work and a discussion
keeps going and going at some point it's
like we have to stop having the
discussion and make a choice we can't be
in discussion forever it's clear because
the work is for work and at a conference
you know it's right against the norms to
jump up on a stage and being like that's
wrong the idea is like you you carefully
select speakers who might have something
interesting to say to folks and try to
efficiently and in a nice way present
that at a meet-up if someone's being
really aggressive they're always yeah
you know oh I need to go to the bathroom
there's ways out of those kinds of
conflicts or and you and you're talking
face-to-face on the street you know
someone's like standing outside
Starbucks and being like I had better
coffee one time it's like that's weird
that's a weird behavior and then and and
the croissants could be done better I
don't know how but they could this isn't
it so this idea of like a place being
for something I think is really
important and so I had this idea for
intentional communication and so the
idea is that instead of just having a
blank box you're writing to you first
choose some intent my intent is to learn
let's say and I'll get prompted to say
okay what's your background maybe they
started using Elm and they've been doing
java for a long time and the question is
why do I have to explicitly cast between
ants and float when doing math and then
I can submit the post so when that shows
up this question might have been read in
a combative way like why do I have to
explicitly cast between int and float
when doing math or like why do I have to
explicitly cast between like both of
those are valid interpretations of this
text but when you give some background
it's like okay I see where this person
is coming from I can see why they'd be
frustrated with that and it's really
harder to read it in a malicious way so
instead of just having a reply button
maybe you can say okay I can either ask
for clarification or I can give an
answer and so if I say I'm gonna give an
answer again we might have this
structured way of
replying restate the question answer it
and then we can say hey we value
citations we value like people backing
up but evidence or experience so maybe
they give the citation and they can post
it and so again you get to answer and
the person asking says oh that's not the
question I was asking actually so that
can really help clarify and make this
process more efficient so the MCG again
instead of a reply maybe you say ask for
clarification or thank the person and so
there's a couple of things you can add
to this I think that would help so one
is the idea of conversation flows so we
saw someone wants to learn you can
clarify your answer if you choose to
answer they can ask a clarifying
question or thank you now if they
clarify maybe you give another answer
but in the other path where you say hey
maybe can you give me an example to to
clarify your question they can restate
it and then you can answer so the point
here is just that yell angrily isn't one
of the states in the discussion its
unreachable so this isn't to say that
all discussions should be this way
because they're places where you want
self-expression you say hey I had a
really nice time at the park here's a
photo of it and someone says oh that's
great that reminds me of some last week
we were clicking something really nice
and so you can have these cycles but
when someone's doing self expression we
say man that's really like a terrible
thing to say maybe you could have a diss
composition floor that says hey I want
to learn about that perspective I don't
want to tell you it's wrong I just want
to know why I feel that way so it might
be interesting here is like the
discussion flows will be different
depending on the goals of the community
right if it's about learning it might be
one way if it's about self-expression it
might be another way and maybe you want
safety valves to jump around so another
thing that I think is interesting is say
discussions happening and it's getting
really out of control and it's like hey
this is nice and then by the end they're
like your mom is a bad person and she
[Music]
Minoo through a bicycle on the ground
I don't know so like this is where you
don't really want things to go so one
thing that might be interesting is when
you see someone about to reply say hey
what would be a successful conclusion to
this interaction or would it be easier
to chat for five minutes like is there
somewhere to take this that's gonna be
more constructive like what do you want
to get out of this another thing that
might be really valuable so we talked
about private fever site upload downvote
stuff when someone gets downloaded they
say they think to themselves these
people could just can't take it you know
I outsmarted them and they can't accept
that but the people might actually be
saying man that was pretty rude and
uncalled for
and so that feedbacks not reaching that
person and they feel increasingly
alienated by these kinds of reactions
furthermore these buttons sort of
uniquely pick out like I'm mad oh I like
that so what we might be able to do
instead is say hey for any post here's a
couple things that you might notice
about it is it off topic is it helpful
and if the goal of the place is to help
professionals maybe these are the ones
you want to choose but if the goal is
helping beginners maybe you want to
choose scary verse encouraging or
confusing verse clear and if the place
is about self-expression maybe you want
to choose funny and downer so there's a
bunch of extras I'm running out of time
so I'm going to skip but there's a lot
of cool things to do here so some people
may be looking at this and thinking if a
planned culture necessarily meant
uniform but like hey like all this
planning is going to ruin these
communities so I found this this book it
says if planned culture necessarily
meant uniforming regimentation it might
indeed work against further evolution if
men were very much alike they would be
less likely to hit upon or design new
practices and a culture which made
people as much alike as possible might
slip into a standard pattern from which
there would be no escape that would be
bad design but if we are looking for a
variety we should not fall back on
accident many accidental cultures have
been marked by uniformity and
regimentation so this is from a book
called Beyond freedom and dignity by BF
Skinner
and I think this is one of the clearest
books that sort of recognizing that
there are these people who understand
choice architectures and that freedom
doesn't help you escape from choice
architectures like design of other
choice architectures is a way to deal
with that so ultimately I'm not here to
say like here's one way that's right or
the others it's like people are gonna
have different priorities depending on
you know their life and their
experiences
I think the point that's important is
that there's a lot of people in
open-source communities who are getting
hurt right so like it's hard emotionally
to work on these kinds of projects you
see people around you getting hurt and
just saying well people are just
expressing themselves isn't solving the
question and we have these very
influential people controlling billions
of dollars who have particular goals for
what happens in these communities so I
hope that's an interesting way to think
about the hard parts of open-source and
I have a bunch of references if you're
interested in looking back on things and
I hope people will explore through
programming like creating the
communities that we kind of talked about
maybe exploring intentional
communication and maybe it will be
beautiful maybe people won't use it
maybe people will use it and then it
will just become another tool for
engagement it's likely we'll see but
thank you very much for your attention
and consideration
[Applause]